right now it's time for my second 1970
recipe challenge
I beat Jermaine Grizz duck into a pulp
can Angie Peters make it one all are you
ready I'm ready
no chef what are you cooking I'm gonna
cook white chocolate mousse with a hint
of mint so why did you choose this dish
because it's a dish I know I can make
well right is this the only lost on
MasterChef oh yeah this is the one on
MasterChef that they said was restaurant
standard that'll be the one Gordon that
we're talking about here I like making
pudding I do love making desserts nice
absolutely lovely oh man look it's a
buff and trim you don't look like you
enjoy pudding seriously you are built
like a movie no but look at my doctor
said to me
good god end you don't like a bison so
chocolate mousse
I'll make an arene I sort of hazelnut
praline still look like nice little
toffee nuts lovely and into the fridge
to set in this bowl I've got the cream
and the egg whites I look at the size of
them big strong boy like you and you
can't use a hand whisk there's no need
this is convenience you lazy man oh geez
for 38 years of age yes there's not a
wrinkle there's not a dimple I mean how
can we look so pristine black don't
crack
look that's what they say let's know if
you go to the hood that's what they say
black don't crack the creme fraiche goes
into the cream and then just make a
little well in the middle they get your
chocolate and put your chocolate in
there and then from there a tablespoon
of coffee to cure and then from there
orange zest yeah you've got a tray
you've greased it and you put chocolate
on that yeah what's that choco got a
taste-off handy Peter taste of chocolate
grease so and they use electric whisk I
three called a whip my cream by hand
yeah little girl used to using your
son's like that on a daily basis I'm not
also I don't stay in the nation for 20
years you're one of these new
flash-in-the-pan people flash in the pan
yeah flash in the pan tamer in 20 years
yeah alone children's BBC oh no alive
and kicking dozen eyes did you win that
no where did you come uh second
seriously yeah second to be knocked out
you see the consistency here 2nd 3rd 3rd
4th losing the second oh la la I
it's very Chevy praline back in the
rolling pin and crush your nuts and just
lightly sprinkle them through the mousse
I'm a big lover of white chocolate yes
but I'm not too sure about the
peppermint hmm I think what you'll find
when you try mine Gordon right when it's
announces the winner right is that
peppermint and mint and white chocolate
go together
right ok right time to serve yes here
come the bad boys I'm gonna put a few
nuts at the bottom a little like two
little milk and coffee these mum used to
make before I went to school Oh careful
a little dusting of icing sugar there
they look [ __ ] amazing done let the
best man win yes yes careful careful
careful